previously on raft all right what is
do we have another heading for another
island that we need to get to
i think tangaroa is the next kangaroo
definitely next run
oh my what in the hell is ahead of us
oh oh jesus that's the thing
is that's the thing what is that that's
a dome
that reminds me of my bald head i think
the tower ain't going to make this one
boss
no no no no we go in here we go in here
i think the buck teeth are going to
shear the roof right off
we win these we win these we win these
we win these we
win our construction is sturdy this will
hold up oh cliffhanger
wow this is cool
[Music]
i will say cards on the table my other
group that i play with this
you just basically finished the game so
i've done all this so i'm going to try
not to like
be an a-hole and spoil things okay
but the the electric water purification
system
uh-huh is really cool and we should get
water there is a battery-powered water
purification system
that feeds into a water tank that you
can water pipe to your sprinklers
so you so all you have to do is keep
building batteries
you'll have water so turned on can't
wait no charge batteries
that we need to titanium yeah well we
need the titanium and get you can get
the battery recharger so you can have a
whole
system of batteries being charged
batteries and your sprinklers batteries
in your water purifier i don't actually
know if there's a better automated way
for the biofuel but like
we're okay at biofuel we doing all right
yeah the bottom fuel we got so much of
it we actually don't anymore
what happened we have a lot of materials
we only have three jokes of biofuel
in the uh storage itself unless there's
some over here
no no no it would have been over there
uh i i i
who's doing that where is it right here
i think it's a seagull i know what it is
wait i was just wondering where it was
you're welcome
we don't have a sprinkler for the water
in the animal pen which is too bad was
that something we could build really
easily or should we just skip it since
we're at this island anyway
we should do this island but then if we
want to do something if we finish the
island and we want to do something that
system is
really fun yeah no i want to build i
love
building really nice things i know it
doesn't seem like that because of all
the videos i've made
i do enjoy building all the garbage that
you've made
i know but there's never any time for it
i do just like taking
that time aside man yeah man i like just
taking time i think it's more fun
it's just like limitations with
recording and editing like it's tough i
don't want to make my editor do too much
you know hey i was right here on it all
right let's go in this place you guys
ready make sure you got food
bring double bottles of water if you
have two bottles make sure you have
make sure you have max stuff because
we're gonna be in here for a while and
it takes a while to get back out to the
raft to like resupply i got i got a full
bottle of water
and some watermelons
you want to run that virus
oh watermelons okay i thought you had
some watermelons yeah man you know
let's go when you're when you're geared
up let's do it i'm geared up my
frickin go boys i'm just refilling some
of the water things
i guess i'm going to empty them oh god i
forgot the shark's a thing
how did he get in here door's closed i
don't know mickey
guys you can't even make fun of me
oh all right watermelons
oh let's do it nerds oh should i get the
uh the metal detector is that useful
here
no we were good with that okay okay okay
cool there are gonna be puzzles though
puzzles yeah who's first
not me all right that's what i mean
here's a trap
i'm wearing a [ __ ] puffer fish yeah
you got puffer fish
dude it looks like a swimming cap it's
cool okay all right as long as it looks
cool
does the green mean anything well means
we're unlocked for the other side
so it means we ain't going that way i
guess okay thank you
uh all right who's first it's it's not a
trap
already oh that's good you should really
try and touch the ladder if you can
it's okay i actually didn't hurt myself
i just thought i was going to i was
preparing pro tip about gravity
is there fall damage i've forgotten
we've never had to encounter it
yes oh what is that what is that oh no
he's always losing things from the boat
before
yeah he's not fine ow he's not fine he's
fine hang on i'm eating food hang on
okay
i'm ready to help now oh got the meat
all right the flesh i just really
wouldn't trust this mutated meat
because that's probably some kind of
mutated flesh is flesh
just to eat it all right i don't
remember what article i read but i did
remember that
when you eat something like say meat
there are fragments of rna then
that you end up ingesting and who knows
what your body does with it but there's
a lot of
information in our dna that's unusually
where is it coming from
like collagen could also be really good
boom you do
you bro mutated bra
hell yeah wade coming in with the hot
banger ideas
yeah i'm getting stuck you gotta stay on
the sidewalk buddy
there you go i'm gonna try and be uh
collegial
and professional and polite as whoever
wanted today
generator storage area all right cool
man i kind of know
there it was oh my ass oh god collegial
all right i am in what am i in storage
oh generator storage and plantation
implantation well you took a right when
we went straight
the hell are they implanting in the
people no
and plantations oh okay okay i was just
implant i spoke inaccurately i mean
maybe i
heard inaccurately wait where are you
flims oh there you are hello
yeah apparently you can go like a plus
sign in the middle we were in this
little cafeteria
found a generator part ooh generator
part we need that how many do we need
three
three i think it's in the journal the
journal
i see a generator part how would we know
about the generator parts we haven't
seen a generator
if we went the other way you would have
seen some stuff
from the other generator no no no the
other way that i went just now when you
guys went to the cafeteria
luke i don't know why but i read that
word and i can't say it any other way
now
pretty sure that's how it's pronounced
yeah probably yeah it's probably
pronounced that way
all right so we need one more jenny part
and we'll be all good
are you using storage i don't know where
you guys went we went out we're on the
hallway outside
okay i just stepped into storage all
right well so here's the generators in
storage
it is it is it is so where's the other
part did you guys like search all of
this area
uh i mean we got three do we need more
than three oh do we have three we have
three yeah
never mind yeah we're good let's go to
the thing all right what's the
probability that this is going to blow
up on us
nothing blows up until later okay cool
what blows up
nothing well stumping but it's we're not
in it
no because it does no we're fine you'll
be fine oh yeah this does look like a
generator
it does and when you look at it it says
to use generator oh
okay oh yeah that's pretty good i don't
know what those things that we're
talking about
but that's pretty good no it's nominal
it's nominal
yeah performance is nominal nominal
binomial nomenclature i got snowmenial
yeah oh i love games
yeah do it you play mark no no i don't
want to do it i'll embarrass myself
i know that's what we're all hoping for
i'm guessing the tape is like the paths
that we can go through it
correct sir okay do you want me to do it
oh god oh yeah
go for it what is the button okay so
that does that is there a rotate button
no they just it's a slightly oh okay
all right i see oh my god this is gonna
take forever then
also there's a secret area you can get
to what secret area
yeah where i want to go there it's
pretty fun
i don't see it look look around look all
over
you don't see anything that looks like
you would be a secret area entrance i
mean i suppose
to go the garage entrance oh wait the
smarty pants what do you mean i see it i
don't see it
oh down there there's metal grate made
yeah that's it i don't need to be coy
you're pretty
video games toy bob that's my favorite
bomb
maybe i don't know oh wow
you guys go get a drink this is going to
take
i'll just go into the hole that you're
making mark no if you go in there you
can't move anything
it's really annoying actually some of
these boxes have
gaps yep i know mark we need to go
that way uh-huh that way
uh-huh oh my god jesus christ everyone
take a bathroom break
surprise five everyone we'll be back
after these messages
from our sponsors uh no
we're back everyone thank you for uh
checking out our sponsors there
can i give up can i just can i give up
trust me
i tried a lot of ways to choose this uh
you gotta do the possible
oh my god come on mark hurry up what are
you doing we're getting close to the
secret mark i like that
yeah uh-huh are you trying to be secret
mark well no i'm just trying to make use
of the straight lines that are already
there so that i don't have to make too
many more
parent decisions i believe in you don't
give up oh man but i
want to give up so many dreams mark
wanting to give up
is the way of us normally and we're
better than us
oh my god oh mark you're so close to
getting to the secret though
yes you see it you see it i'm aware okay
so
but we need to get oh a street yes we do
i'm gonna bring these pieces more around
so that we i like that thanks man
actually there's a gap over here that i
could take advantage ooh
you found the second gap look at this
guy i
hate both of you just go thank your subs
or something i
just give me a break greg thank you for
the five months marisa
thank you for the follow-up
yeah what's in the secret is it worth it
is it really worth all this effort oh
god you just have to slide everything to
the left
yeah come on you're doing it man which
one wait what i'm almost dying of hunger
we've been here so long
the neon green dash that line if you
just removed that line for the moment
and slid all everything else
you mean you'd be there basically yeah
it's fine it's fine just let me guys
backseat is i offered you the front seat
this doesn't mean mark
i think you're under utilizing your
pluses i think that would be yeah i know
i'm getting there questioning the secret
mark you made us question you
okay it's like i just wish i could press
my keyboard for this [ __ ] it's
it's infuriating to aim at stuff is
pretty terrible
actually it's it's like this is this
this would be a great control scheme i
know
well i i'm aware of how okay you don't
need to hype it up
you can go now great job everybody
that's not the one the secret
i found it i found a secret it's right
here look at the secret room oh i bet
it's crazy
oh my god this is oh hello there's a
machete
there's some briefcases there's some
titanium ores
actually the titanium [ __ ] oh no is he
coming
no no it doesn't matter there's no
reason to now
look here you want us know you want to
see you want to see i don't want to see
actually i was in the briefcase
just just materials no here look mark
you can come back i'll put it it'll be
just as cool
i don't want it i'm not gonna do it okay
then we're gonna come on up buddy
i'll grab the back up wait are you
moving stuff yeah moving forward
mark
[Laughter]
oh god he betrayed us now i mean
wouldn't you oh look mark you solved the
puzzle yeah i just wanted to um i need
to get the plus
over uh but no you can get there can't
you the door is good can you
hold the door oh well well i could uh
actually let me um
oh not there this let me if i just move
this and then um
yeah you can slide that one twice right
and you're good yeah it should be good
here
look at puzzle master mark over here
okay
that's uh yep mr i can't do it not only
got us the secret he got us
everything i mean i knew i could do it i
just didn't want to do it as a thing
but the secret was right there it was
yeah look look at the secret oh you
can't anymore
it's just a [ __ ] it's just don't even
worry about it
oh let's look at the next part's even
cooler better than any
secrets oh god i'm dying of thirst hang
on
yeah you got to keep eating and drinking
and that's part of the game yeah this is
a
quite a level surface access wow i'll go
back to get more water soon because i
actually am running out of water
when we get to the surface we can open
up the the upstairs exits which is
let's just go in and out no problem
water oh
yeah yeah yeah water pipe yeah
note the engines are burning we're
sailing them but to note
the reds are burning we're sailing them
what does that mean
ceiling i i might have skipped a couple
of lines of them
you didn't tell me about that right i
forgot about that front
run right now
that's this way oh thank god this door
still opens please don't wait
wait where are you where are we going
what do you mean where are we
oh you can breathe in the hallways you
can breathe in the hallways just gotta
find little spots i'm coming back to
find out if they know
we're coming back back i'm coming back
you didn't tell us that we ran the way
we came this way this way
with you wait wait probably wait
you gotta go get up
i found a little air okay good all right
there's one there's air right here mark
okay cool i'll go back for weight i
guess okay
oh do you see us come here where are you
wait where are you where are you
oh there it is here all right come come
this way hold on i need to get this air
real quick
there's air in here there's there's a
whole bunch of air in here we're back in
the puzzle room
wow glad we're here
oh plantation this is the way we want it
to be
i'm pretty sure this is the way whoa
dude planks flying i'll read this note
for you guys
we're headed for the habitat the boy and
the dog we're going to need a boat
there you go all right cool i'm not
going to open any more hatches or doors
it burned me last time i'm never doing
it again
i literally opened the door she said no
there are no trap mark there are no
traps here
see i don't believe you there's no more
traps here it's fine there's no
wardrobe yeah what was the other way i
opened a door over the other way i need
to know
yeah we should check out the other way
why what's this way am i doing the wrong
stuff there's a door
i don't trust this way it's electricity
this way
food's getting a little tight gang you
need food mirk
no i'm okay for now but i've officially
okay
we don't need to go this way we've been
this way wait what i was going the right
way
oh this is back out this is out this is
how we got in from the raft
does that mean there's water this way do
you need water
i've got enough for two sips that's like
a whole water bar
there's food in here we should go to
mark mark's
on the plantation it's food
i'm going to take it all
i wouldn't recommend i've got a machete
i've got two
that's true he does have double machetes
wow that's really impressive
the secret room had a food thievin
machete good for killing food thieves
food thievin machette i got a note i'll
read it to you
tape yeah we got a major beetle
infestation in the banana plants i think
that's a euphemism for someone got an
sp he's got the beetle in the banana
plants if you know what i mean
i hit that with better but i didn't even
slow them down cockpit won't respond to
my calls and beetles will strip down
everything if we don't stop them
all right and you little monsters let's
see how you like the taste of a vacuum
that's this is he's got a penis pump
he's got crabs like this guy's got
issues
now i do see a little power junction
over here does that turn it off
uh i think that's what the tape is for
if i remember
oh i think you got it like oh three tape
okay i got one tape over here i got
two tops in here okay grab one
electricity okay there we go
okay did it oh god it just opened the
door it's still electrified
oh good oh that's right ah it remains
dangerous i remember now
careful i did this not that long
okay it just takes a little health and
stuns you a little
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i did i
did that thing where i got
you doing today jump up you guys all
right
what happens when you get electrocuted
yeah you've never seen weight
electrocuted oh no no no no no
is it mar from home alone yeah yeah or
my
skeleton show yeah that's the sound bar
yeah kind of like a bad arnold
schwarzenegger
that's your arnold impression that was a
really terrible man
[Laughter]
now we need more tape
wipe uh it's one of those it's one of
those universal items
of uh you only have oh this is surface
access boys
i like the sound of that me arnold
uh-huh hey arnold
please let me know keep working on that
you it's not even that the surface it's
not well then what it is if it's not
even the surface it's
not the surface
[Music]
that is an evil ass face look at that
face
isn't this the guy who founded uh
bioshock
max landschoff founder of the tangoroa
project
savior of earth's finest whose earth's
oh uh wait why can't i see the note
is this the note things have gotten
quiet since they cut off water the
cockpit
security teams still go on patrols and
their ridiculous golf carts
rounding up any pets they can find
ow [ __ ] hey i'm dying to a robot can you
help me no
oh my god owie
kind of tough all right oh that's right
you get key cards to go in buildings
from these fellows
okay so now they'll unlock your reading
just that was a little scary
yeah it's fine a bunch of weenies that
was a killer robot
so this thing opens this thing that says
exit uh-huh
if you come over here you can it open
it's like an airplane thing it has like
a cool
you'll see
well there's four of these we can open
the one that's near the raft and then
then it's the odds that i beat you there
to it
zero percent that's fair that's fair
the shark also still exists yeah i was
gonna see if i could kill the shark in
time but uh
i didn't trust myself not without dual
machetes
you're right you're right about that
look i found the one by the wrap
hey that's cool man i could have beat
you there i couldn't have
the one by the raft is the one to the
right from where mark was incorrect
oh our raft isn't reinforced we're gonna
lose a lot of ground to the shark while
we're in here i think
reinforce we can reinforce the raft if
you have a [ __ ] ton of metal
uh ingots you can reinforce and the
shark can't destroy reinforced raft bits
oh why didn't what why do i only know
about this now
yeah what because why don't you look at
things with your eyes i don't know
well first of all my feelings into i
don't know what i'm looking for
it's in the construction tool you know
where all the stuff that we construct
actually you know it's the thing i've
actually never really built much of the
raft so i
i am unfamiliar yeah no that was never
my job
all you need is two nails and one ingot
to make one reinforced
yeah well we don't have a lot of nails
and ingredients that's for sure
we never really made that a priority to
get i don't know if we ever really
followed through many of our priorities
we were kind of like oh we need this we
get like one
we have 32 ingots yeah we got a decent
amount and this titanium should be
yeah you got the titanium so we do have
enough titanium for the whatever we
needed the battery recharger but we also
got some more titanium bob
found uh some more titanium in there
nice in the secret room that i never
know
yeah in the super cool secret room dude
yeah that's really cool man
i'm going back in the city i don't need
this let's go back in the secret room
i'm gonna do is move the boxes around i
don't want to do it
not that hard i know he puzzled yeah
yeah mark it's not that hard
guys why are you bullying me when
wayne's such an easy target
for me because obviously we wanted a
challenge today
all right i'm gonna reinforce uh areas
of our raft oh you still on the raft
is there anything to scavenge in the oh
my god this
freaking butler i just imagine him going
good morning sir
i don't know who that imitates other
than like that little bird from lion
king
zazu you being zazu up in here
yeah all right the front edge is
reinforced and i've burned through
all of the all of the ingots that we had
that's good enforcement though all those
nets are safe now
a barber oh
so it actually just can't damage it at
all now that that's like that correct
sir
that's oh that makes my loins tingle
your frosting my loins are frothy make
sure
your groin gold go if anyone's ghrelins
are frothing
that's a problem oh they're frothing
like a felt that doesn't work they're
um they're frothing like sarah
mclaughlin in the
arms of my loins i don't i don't like
that image that's not a good image yeah
man we're really burning through the
food here i might need to do some food
preparations oh man no way we have all
those fish that we haven't cooked
because they're in the non-cook fish
everything's so nice here why don't we
just live on this in this
city i'm saying the first time i came
through here i was like all right we're
here let's stay
do you want to see our sad droopy
animals droopy are they starving to
death or something are they yeah we
don't have any water on their
grass and they're all well
[Music]
they're they're drooping the animals are
drooping
good a never ending thing taking care of
these
little shits is why i'm not a parent
it's like they're alive
or some dumb [ __ ]
for now probably not for long while we
tolerate their existence
do you think if there's a higher power
it's what it says about us like they're
alive
while we tolerate their existence i mean
almost
definitely if you're looking around and
yeah that's probably it can you imagine
some higher being
especially if they made us what
expectations they must have had and then
they got
humans and they're just sitting up there
just like oh [ __ ]
we'd be like a kindergarten art project
that like they brought home to mom and
mama's like oh
thank you it's so great i'll put it
around the fridge
just show me some c's on the report card
come on humanity
do you think that there's an alien
species out there that is like the
golden
child and you know god spends all of his
time
on that one race is like oh you're so
perfect and we're just like
with our nukes and our forks and plastic
and
[ __ ] like i'm sorry our
forks we're sorry for staying in the
sauce
we're going to get into someone we're
going to be so jealous of like the
attention they get
i mean i'm jealous now they're gonna
show us like a video like where they
facetimed uh god or whatever
they're like oh yeah look i was just
chat with the other day we're like he's
not responding to my emails or anything
i'm sorry did you guys not get god's uh
thanksgiving invitations
it's called existential dread ah it's
not really so much
dread is just a sorrow existential
disappointment
yeah pretty much well you know if i had
to give us you know
like a report card grade on how we're
doing i'd say not
well so you know i'm not surprised no on
god's fridge we're not gonna be putting
anything up there but what about the
tiny penis statues
hey nice man tangaroa that's what i said
i see a painting of a bear sucking a
dude's penis nose
i'd want to see this painting am i
mistaken as to what i'm looking at this
dude is like yes a
phallic no say that yes i don't know
what i'm looking mark
huh mark where are you do you want to
come find where you are how are you
going to ever find each other
it just looks like a bear sucking a
dude's penis nose yeah i'll text you
guys i
doubt that's what that is hang on this
image is coming in mark you're going to
change your mind okay all right hang on
i'm waiting for a bear sucking a penis
nose all right
oh okay you know
oh god i don't see yeah if you look at
it from a distance and you squint your
eyes yeah you know what you're
wide open and i'm face first in this
painting i see it we
judged too quickly really yeah judged
too quickly
uh i can't show you guys you gotta
google that yourself just google bear
sucking penis nose
and tell me what you find
[Laughter]
that is the gem that we needed from
today's stream
please google bear sucking penis nose
some i don't know what some people are
finding when they're googling this up
but people are having a bad time
i wouldn't do what mark said i wouldn't
whoa you shouldn't i wouldn't
yeah why would anyone do what i just
said
and it was horrible i should be able to
kill things with an
axe i should be able to that should be a
thing i can do
yeah now okay you know what i'm gonna
die oh
tape okay i got three pieces of tape now
for whatever good that does
but i couldn't kill that for the the
swamp swamp
thing yeah that's it the swamp oh you're
fast i don't know why but i was gonna
culminate in fat
and i was about to be very disappointed
in you win
no no oh you're fat
very rude you're so rude wayne you
didn't say that though
right sure we were all thinking you were
gonna say it
why i don't know this is more about you
what you guys think of me than it does
about
me being oh god just trying to swim
that's what that's what the world needs
right now yeah yeah yeah what he said
what he said
what i did
gold trimmed bowls yeah no everything is
lovely whoever earth's finest were
they really had modern tastes cactus
dildo
oh they have cactus dildos what do we do
with the tokens
there's uh i'm not gonna tell you figure
it out they are right
there's probably some kind of rich
vending machine for rich people
all right keep your secrets i'm riding
gambling oh god i'm sorry did you just
frodo me
yeah yeah you didn't keep your secrets
hey it's my favorite meal
i'm falling i'm okay i need to come back
for a new machete but uh
i've been doing pretty good here just
ate a fruit salad
very nice very happy nice dude nice nice
nice
how do i make a machete just a metal
lookout just do it and look at it and
then do it
a machete we got some extra biofuel as
well
in there i found a couple hey i brought
some bio fuel too
hey cool man that's awesome good job
should we be worried about the fact that
this place looks like it's totally
inhabited but there's no people around
so that's not what you should worry
about okay that's fine it's fine what i
imagine happened
is that the mechanics got tired of
dealing with the rich people so they
programmed the robots to attack which is
why they're attacking us
and the rich people were like oh my fur
coat and then they just died
and the mechanics well they didn't have
the the passcodes to get into like the
fancy
locked fridges and stuff and so they
ended up starving to death
in order to try to survive they went out
into the water
and were never seen or heard from again
all right cool
i'm going back in all good do it where
did we find this
water purification machine that you were
talking up so much
did we research titanium yet research it
yeah you got to put a titanium ingot
into the research table and research
that bad boy but i did not know that
sometimes you just find recipes but we
did not find a new recipe
okay south park wade actually i was
going for uh
that new final fantasy it's not new
anymore but the final fantasy where the
dude's always like
i discovered a new recipe every 10
seconds what are you talking about man
you know no i don't which is why i asked
what the hell are you talking about
final fantasy
like 15. yeah there's too many 17.
i i haven't played the remake of seven i
feel bad about that i
like seven was a really big game in my
like childhood it's only like the first
half of seven or something though isn't
it isn't there like another one coming
out
what don't spoil that for me i thought
that was
common knowledge or something isn't it i
might be wrong i don't even know
don't spoil the story of the game that i
played the crap out of of when i was a
kid how dare you
sorry i didn't mean to spoil the plot of
we want
two games this is this an apartment what
the hell
yeah these people live in the lap of
luxury tell you what this cannot be an
apartment
oh it's an office okay oh shocking
development
i've got so many gift cards from these
guys heads what's happening
wade's just spouting words off what's
going on with that
all right i'm gonna stop with the food i
think we got enough food for now
oh my god i'm not done i'm going to come
explore or we're never going to
accomplish anything
hey we're going to accomplish stuff i'm
a customer
i'm accomplishing great things i'm
making something out of myself
i'll show
[Music]
son of a watch your language fun
you're close frick don't test me
shoot dang it oh my god
ass oh bear sucking penis nose
there it is you found it i did it's a
different one but
a different painting altogether or just
a different version of the same painting
same painting different place
oh so but there's like multiple penis
nose sucking bears in this town
probably you know that's probably what
ended this society
they were very very refined people but
had odd tastes so
really it collapsed it was inevitable do
you ever just say a sentence out loud
and you're like man
if i had ever known that was gonna be a
sentence i would say during my career
yeah no i'm pretty proud of everything
i've done and said another
penis nose another in the lobby this
time
huh it's almost like this game reuses
assets or
the people here have very specific
tastes another one
maybe they only have one artist and he
just kind of does what he does
that is true if it was like an insular
society
and they're like greg please it's a good
painting anything
but the bear penis come on
there's a painting of a guy trapped in a
bush and he's pointing like you better
go that way stay away from this bush
i think you better check that bush man
something's in there
no i see i i just came across the exact
one you're talking about
he's stuck in a bush he's like a bird go
that way
don't come to me yeah no you i i
shouldn't have questions yours to these
places i'm trying to have a fun jolly
exploration like my friends but i can't
get inside nothing
well they're like some fancy doors like
a red or green look right now i
know i've done this before uh just in
case you haven't done this before bob
one to watch
you gotta kill the uh robots take their
key cards
oh i think i'm in a building that one of
you is in because i just
had to call the elevator i hear an
elevator moving
that's right i'm in mark's building [ __ ]
yeah i there's a way to get out here for
zip lines i just haven't found it yet
are you on the top floor mark or the
knockout yeah i went top floor i found
the way out
towards the uh zip all right have you
explored the other floor
uh yes oh okay well i'll let you know if
there's anything
zip-line-able that you need to know
about
well this is a little silly oh hey mark
uh
oh hey
have you ever heard that joke before
mark has never said that to you no
mark how the ass did you get outside uh
yeah let me
come get you man i there's nothing out
here anyway i thought there would be a
way to the center building no there's
definitely a way to climb i think isn't
there
uh maybe maybe whoa oh hey
hello this way oh [ __ ] i was in here i'm
just an idiot
yeah so this zipline is just at slightly
too low an angle to go down that way
so that's another caught maybe if you
push me can you push me push me
push him don't jump off be careful
no can we make that jump across not
really
you can like get kind of a running start
but it's not enough what if you want to
feel like just
[Music]
so
bye